What's new in Google's IoT
PlatformPlatform?
Ubiquitous computing at Google
Stage 3
5-17-17
.
High everyone, this morning.
It's really excited to see you
all here.  So my name is Wayne
Piekarski, and I'm a developer
advocate at Google and today I'm
excited to talk about all the
cool new things we're doing on
the Internet of Things.  This
enables what we refer to
ubiquitous computing.  There's a
lot of new and interesting
products and tools of interest
to develop that I'm going to
highlight in the talk, and them
released today right now.  a
bunch of new announcements
during the keynotes.  There's
all kinds of new things.  We'll
do a whirlwind tour of all of
Google's products related to so
that you can find out more what
you can do for yourself.  So
importantly, here at I/O we have
interesting engineers and PMs
and leaders from different teams
that work on products I'm
talking about.  Take advantage
of that and go and see them in
the sandboxes and so forth.  So
let's get started with our tour.
we know, computing has evolved
over the years, so we started
from mainframes and then we
moved to desktops and laptops
and then phones, and so every
decade or so we shrink our
electronics.  Now we're at
wearables.  If we go any smaller
of a wearable, humans can't
interact with them anymore
because our fingers can't touch
it.  There's a limit to what we
can do with shrinking
electronics.  What's happening
now is that computers are
embedded into everyday  use
different devices depending on
what we try to do, so we use a
laptop to write documents or
e-mails, a TV for videos, a
phone for things away from home
and a wearable when running and
something when we're driving.
So there's all these different
computing experiences that are
suitable for what you're doing
at the
time.  Now we're at a point
where we have thermostats and
light bulbs and basic
electronics Internet-enabled,
but we can do more than that.
We're moving to a world where
computing is going to be
everywhere, assisting users with
their day and solving problems
we didn't realize existed and we
look back and go, wow, this
really changed everything.  So
while phones were bigger than PC
s, Internet of Things is going
to be even bigger than phones.
It's going to be incredible.  We
use the term ubiquitous
computing to describe this.
It's technology accessible to
the user wherever they are and
whenever they are trying to do.
Today we talk about what
platforms Google provides, and
what developer tools Google
provides to help support this.
in the past we trained users to
install apps on other phones
with icons.  You click an icon
for each app.  Now we have
devices that don't have screens,
so we need to think differently
about computing and what it
means.  Take the user's context
into consideration.  What time
is it?  What's the user's
location?  What are they doing?
need to make good decisions
based on those kinds of things.
need to think of your platform
as a view into your service now,
so it's no longer a single app
or single website.  service
needs to be ubiquitous and
everywhere and it needs to work
on all platforms.  we want a
single, seamless experience to
keep the users happy.  With that
in mind, a little intro, let's
get started talking about what
consumer products are provided
that consumers have right now.
We'll start talking with
Android.
Android, they announced 2
billion devices run Android, so
that's incredible.  We have
Android phones, tablets,
wearables and TV.  They also
involve the same infrastructure,
so they all work on Google
Play, and you build your apps
using Android Studio, and the
apps run on the device.  We do
things like that right now, but
many have only written a phone
app before.  One thing you might
want to consider is extending
your app to wear or Android TV.
year I gave a talk to Google
I/O.  There's a few tweaks and
change the UI a little bit, and
it runs on those devices as
well.  These are new
opportunities to have different
kinds of users looking at your
application, because there are
times looking at something on a
TV is better and sometimes other
things are better, and you need
to take advantage of those
things.  Now, phones can do --
sorry.  Android in general does
interesting things.  They do
apps, games, sensor processing,
3D graphics and audio.  There's
interesting capabilities we get
to talk about later on.  I'm
just going to highlight Android
Auto as well.  It's different in
that it's a templated user
interface in that you can build
messaging and media apps as
well.  So if you're a company
that makes media or messaging
apps, you add some extensions to
your Android app, and then it
will work when the user plugs in
their phone into a vehicle or
when they install it into one of
those cars that you can see out
in the demo area.  So we have
this big eco-system of Android
devices that solve different
needs.   there's no one device
perfect for everything.  Some
are better than others,
depending on the context the
user is in, but they all solve
different problems depending on
the time, where the user is,
whether they're at home or in
the living room.  So that's
Android.  Now, you may have also
heard at the
keynote about Google Home and
Google Assistant.  We'll cover
those today and how that is
ubiquitous computing.  The
Assistant is now available.  It
was available on Google Home,
but we announce it's available
on a lot of Android phones out
there, and also it's coming soon
on wear, TV, and auto.  So
we're bringing the Assistant to
different platforms, and it
allows the user to have a
conversation with it to get
things done.  So the basic
Google Assistant is you talking
to Google, but there's a
third-party library that allows
you to build your own extensions
as well.  The Google Assistant
is interesting because it
supports both text and
voice-based audio inputs and
outputs.  Once again, that
depends on the context of what
the user is doing.  If they're
in a movie theater, they can
type on their phone.  If they're
driving, they can speak.  If
they stand in the kitchen with
their hands dirty, they can
speak as well.  So you use a
different input and output
modality depending on what the
user is doing.  As we can see,
context is important, and that's
going to help us with all these
platforms.  So these were the
consumer platforms, and now
we're going to talk about the
possibilities for you as a
developer and how to extend
them.  Consumers have these
devices already.  There's
billions of phones and TVs and
wearables and so forth out
there.  You want to be able to
take advantage of them, and how
can you doing that?  There's a
bunch of new options you'll find
very interesting.  So the first
thing that's really cool is
that we announced recently the
developer preview for Android
Things.  It's Google's new Platt
to remember so support the
development of IoT devices based
on Android.  One of the really
interesting things about Android
Things is the use of a SoM
which you see on the slides over
there.  A SoM is a tiny board
with a CPU, memory, wireless and
all the important things that
make the device do what it does.
a single board with a common
set of software.  These SoMs are
made in bulk quantities to you
can pay reasonable prices for
them.  You plug them into your
own custom developer board to
test them, but you can build
your own custom development
boards depending on your needs
for the kind of application
you're building, because you
don't want to embed a full
development board into a product
you're selling.  The SoM
contains hard-to-design
components.  When you do
electronic manufacturing, there
are high-speed electronics and
low-speed electronics.   require
really skilled design people
who really know how to build
things that run at 1 gigahertz
and there's a lot to take into
place.   we can build at home.
going to talk tomorrow where we
go through how to make your own
boards for an Android Things
device at home.  We'll talk
about that tomorrow.  The nice
thing about SoMs is it's our
initiative to Democrat ties
hardware development.  We make
it fun for prototyping.  You can
take a board and build
something, but there's a road to
production.  You don't have to
switch hardware and SWECH your
software platform.  You can use
the same hardware and software
for the prototype and the
commercial product that you can
sell in quantities.  That's one
of the really important things
about Android Things and our
architecture based on SoMs.  So
the way you get started with
Android Things is you start with
one of these developer boards,
so I've got samples on the slide
here.  You can see that the
developer board is quite large.
SoM is plugged into it.  The
SoM is the really small
component on the bottom left,
and it's on the top left of the
other one as well.  So the SoM
just plugs in, but the developer
board has breakout pins for
every interface you need as a
hacker or a maker making
prototypes.  So there's USB
ports, audio, GPIO pins, I2C
buses and things like that.
you build your prototype and you
put a bread board next to it
and run jumper wires across.
When you finish, take that
custom board and shrink it down.
But it's nice because you can
test both and use the same SoM.
So in tomorrow's talk, we're
going through an example so my
colleague Dave actually built
this L.E.D. candle project.  We
wanted to test how hard it would
be.  On the left Dave built a
prototype which had a large
board with the LEDs and
resistors and wires on it
plugged into the Edison
debugging board.  We tested it.
we're happy with it, then we
used PCB software and designed
the schematic and had it
fabricated.  We had it
fabricated cheaply.  A lot of
places will fab boards quickly
and easily.  You can see on the
right that we have our LED
prototype sitting in the plastic
shell, and then there's a lid
we put on top of it.  The board
we built is almost the size of
the SoM, and that's an example
of how you can build a cheap
board, build it in with a SoM
and embed and sell it.  I was
quite excited we could hand
solder this and build the
prototypes.  helps to increase
the time to do for prototyping,
because you don't want to wait a
month every time you want to
iterate on something because
electronics can be hard to do
compared to
Now, the one thing about
working with that
if you had to write code that
processed the strings
separately, you would have a
hard time doing it.  We have a
tool called API.AI that we use
to build nice conversation
actions.  Let's talk about APIA.
has a simple user interface and
don't need to be a programmer
to use it.  What you do is give
it example sentences of things
that you want the system to
process.  So there's a video I
made a couple of months ago
before we built this personal
chef example.  You can say I'm
hungry and I want a hot soup
because it's cold outside and
chicken sounds good to me and
I'd like a cold dessert and want
it right now.  You could give
complex sentences and APII could
extract out the key phrases of
sentences and pass it to your
web hooks so you can do
something with it.
They use Machine Learning
techniques you program by typing
in these examples sentences.
It learns from you, and then as
users use your action, it then
learns from that as well, and if
there's mistakes you can
correct it and it trains this
model to understands the
different phrases that people
are going to give you.  So it's
a really neat of way of building
conversations and makes it
really easy.  MRENT offy of
people build their own assistant
app.  It's cool what you can do
with it.  We have great samples
on how to do that. if you're
beginner, start with that.
Finally, we mentioned in the
keynote today that the Assistant
runs on phones and the Google
Home device and we have other
platforms coming seen, but the
key thing to remember.  I've had
a few people ask me this.  If
it runs on the phone, how do I
build an APK around that?  The
answer is all of the actions on
Google is hosted in the cloud
somewhere.  You can use whatever
cloud provider you want, but
the action lives in the cloud
somewhere because it's available
to every device, Google Home,
portable devices and so forth.
device can install apps on the
device itself.  Look at the
document takes.  It's something
if you're interested in building
a conversational interaction
with your service, because
people are driving, their
walking, doing things.  not
always at a phone or computer,
and this is a way to enable more
capabilities for your service
or platform.  So one thing we're
announcing at Google I/O this
year is a new contest.  We want
to see the cool assistant
appears that you build, so we
launch this contest at I/O to
encourage that.  We have over 20
different prizes and one is a
trip to Google I/O next year.
You don't have to wait in line
for a ticket.  a prize.  We want
to encourage you to go out
there and build a system action
and submit them and try them out
and see how it goes.  There's a
link G.CO DZ actions challenge
to learn more about this.
This is the Google Assistant
that you build into devices
yourself.  not limited to a
phone or Google Home.  Make your
own crazy device.  In the
sandbox area we have deep local,
who is a partner of ours and
they made a drink making machine
and press a button and tell it
what you want and have a
conversation with it.  Say
things like I'm thirsty and I
feel like whatever the drink is.
With the power the APII, we
understand what you ask for, and
it helps to tell you and helps
to understand
what you want.  It's really
amazing what they can do.  So
recently we announced in the
magpie magazine a kit that's
that cardboard bock at the top
there. a nice kit because it's a
cardboard box with a button,
speaker, microphone and wraps
around it.  We gave the kits
away to tens of thousands of
people, and every one of them
has the Google assistant built
into it.  You push the button
and talk to it and do stuff to
it.  I'm curious to see what we
do with this stuff because the
possibilities are endless.  You
can talk to your cocktail
machine or whatever.  It's quite
fun.  How can you
embed the Google Assistant to
work in your project.  We have a
dedicated sec about embedded
the Google Assistant in.  The
engineers go through code
samples in a lot of detail with
demos, but it's a quick summary
here.  If you look in the box of
the API project, it has
speakers and a button so it's
very simple.  We run on any any
Linux or Android Things device.
The nice thing is that the
software, the API users to talk
to Google is based on GRPC,
which is an OpenSource portable
library to do this interaction.
a week of launching this, we
had people popping up with
contributed projects with
different kinds of platforms.  I
was excited to see the huge
interest in this and the porting
to many different platforms.
really easy.  You can run on
anything.  The next thing is
that you can use a button press
to activate it, because you
don't want to use a hot word.
provide a library that adds
hardware support too, so you can
trigger like we do on consumer
Google Home devices.  Hey,
Google, talk to it, and it does
the recognition and then it does
everything like you do on a
Google Home.  Basically you show
up with your hardware, speaker
and microphone, and then you
hook it altogether and then you
use actions on Google to
implement the rest of your
functionality.  The actions on
Google that you build work on
either the device you've made,
BHUT it works on any device that
the
user had their logged into.  a
crazy idea, and I'm interested
to see what other crazy ideas
people come up with and see it
online and so forth.
that was a little tour on
Google's stint and the actions
on Google and the Assistant SDK.
do more for that for your
users.  Connect up your devices
and coordinate them, and now
we're going to talk about how we
go about doing that.
Google I/O we announced this
smart home initiative.  So we
supported consumer devices for a
while, but now we open it up to
third-party developers so
anyone can build a device that
integrates with our Smart Home.
you go to the tent over there,
you can see a variety of things
we have with commercial things
available but now you can build
your own and you can integrate
them into the home graph.  The
home graph is a diagram of sorts
that knows the state of all of
the devices that are in your
house.  Your light bulbs, your
thermostats and doors.  It
remembers how bright your lights
are at any particular time and
what color they're set to.  With
the home graph storing this
information, you then have the
ability to speak to the Google
Assistant and to make changes to
it.  You can say things like,
make it warmer, or turn off all
the lights.  Or turn -- dim the
lights just a little bit.  Dim
the lights just a little bit
requires knowledge of the
current brightness and then what
a little bit means, and so
Google handles all of the
parsing of the language to
extract out what to do.  It goes
to the home graph and makes
changes and sends commands to
the devices to change the state
so it matches what the user
desires here.  So device makers
can now build these things
really easily, whereas before it
required a separate app running
on your phone that you would
have to press, but now you can
be sitting back on your couch
and you can just speak to your
Google Home device that does
everything for you.  It's kind
of cool.  So how do you do this?
going to quickly go through an
example.  There's a talk that
goes through this in complete
detail where they're going to
show demos and go through the
examples line by line.  what
happens is we provided a sample,
which is on our developer's
Google.com/action/spothome, and
there's a sample we provided.
spin up the example on your
cloud server of your choice, and
then you submit an action
package that tells the Google
Home that that demo exists.  The
next step is you go to your
phone and you have to register
the devices that you own.  So
you click on your smart home
integration and type in the user
name and password for that
particular OEM's service, and it
returns the credentials to the
Google Home.  So the Assistant.
the Assistant has a log in
token to control your devices.
it comes time for the user when
they say dim the lights a little
bit, now everything springs in
action.  So dim the lights a
little bit go to the home graph.
The home graph decides how
much to lower the dimness of the
light bulb by.  then the light
bulb is center command that's
through the API that we show
you, and then the command
arrives at your cloud service,
and then you can send the
command to your light bulbs
however it's implemented and
change the light bulb state.
really designed to integrate
with existing infrastructures,
because lots of companies have
different light bulbs out there,
and we want to make it easy.
It hooks into cloud
infrastructure very easily.  You
have a really small cloud
service and hook it all in, and
it just works.  Now,
one of the very nice things
about this is we integrate it in
different OEMs so you don't
need to mention the name of the
manufacturer.  It tells all of
them connected to the home
graph.  The other thing you can
do is you can embed the Google
Assistant SDK into a device like
a light bulb, and then you can
talk to the light bulb itself.
when you speak to it light bulb,
you can say turn off, and the
light bulb will turn off.   turn
on all the lights in the house,
and it will send the command
everywhere.  So you have the
ability to embed the Assistant
into the devices itself, and
there's all kinds of
combinations to do here.  The
cocktail machine example is an
example of a device that has the
Assistant built in, and it's a
device of its own that hooks
into the eco-system of things.
that's the really nice thing
about the Google Assistant SDK.
brings embedding devices and
the smart home initiative
together.  So definitely go
check that out in the sandbox
area.  There's a bunch of really
nice demos, and we have
examples to play with to sort of
see how they work.  As a few
other developer products, let's
go through them quickly.  We
have Firebase, so Firebase is an
SDK that many are familiar with
for writing Android apps.  It
works on the web, Android, iOS.
It's a portable library that
runs any.  Firebase cloud
messages is part of that, and it
allows you to deliver quick,
reliable messages to devices to
wake them up.  Normally when you
build IoT devices the quick and
dirty way is to see polling,
where you poll every five
minutes.  That's not efficient,
because if someone says change
the lights, it will take five
minutes.  It's a great way to
deliver messages in your
products between your devices if
that's something you want to
do.  It provides fast updates
and it's available currently
everywhere.  Because Android
Things supports Google Play
services, it then supports all
of the cool features of Firebase
as well.  Firebase also has a
realtime database capability.
So it's cloud-hosted and based
on NoSQL and let us you store
and sync data realtime as well.
Maybe the smart home is not for
you, and you want to do
synchronizing between devices
and you can do that.  Because
Android Things supports all
Firebase out of the box, you can
use this stuff for free without
doing extra work.  engineers on
the team made a sample where he
put Firebase to work on devices
as well.  There's a UL there to
do that.  That's useful for
cheap devices to embed Firebase
into that.  The nice thing about
Firebase, the database, is that
it -- you don't need your own
server.  If you want to
synchronize between devices, you
don't need cloud hosting and we
handle
it.  We provided a whole bunch
of samples for that, so check it
out if you're interested.
Finally, for Firebase, we also
have the ability to store user
generated cone tent,- content,
and it takes a photo and you
want to synchronize it over to a
device running an app you've
got.  This is great because you
can take that photo, and it will
store it in Firebase for you
and make it available to all the
other devices that are part of
your eco-system.  So you can
store photos, videos, large
files.   of nice for things like
this.  Once again, it works on
Android Things.  Some of the
things to use on Android TV as
well.  They're full Android
devices with the same
capabilities as phones, so you
can use it there as well.  And
then just yesterday we released
a blog post where we announced a
new initiative called cloud IoT
core, which is a fully managed
service on the
Google Cloud Platform that
allows to connect multiple
devices to Google Cloud.  The
reason it's cool is it scales
automatically and works anywhere
in the world.  We provide
Endpoints everywhere you don't
have to worry about.  You upload
the data and it works
everywhere in the world and
handles millions of devices.  a
scenario where you have an
enterprise building millions of
thermostats or power meters for
the power company or something.
Every meter logs data every
minute, and there's millions of
them.  Imagine millions of
devices logging data every
minute.  You end up with
terabytes of data really, really
quickly.  Google Cloud is ideal
for this thing because it's
built to run really megalarge
applications.  So we support the
ability to use standardized
MQTT messages, so we support
lots of different protocols like
that.   all the data very
easily, and the nice thing is
you can use cloud services like
BigQuery to analyze the data and
extract out really useful
information that you might not
be able to see the small
datasets.  Once again, we have a
bunch of talks about cloud IoT
as well, we have two.  One is a
combo session about county and
another one is about cloud IoT
and all the concepts.   out
those two talks.  They have
demos and samples and so forth
you can learn more about.  So
we're almost out of time.  So
that was a quick whirlwind tour
of some of the things that
Google provides to support
ubiquitous computing and the
Internet of Things, and we think
they're really useful for
making amazing, powerful, and
secure products that scale to a
worldwide audience, because you
can't just build things small.
to build big because there's
lots of THIPGs outs there.
Every thing has a dedicated deep
dive session at IO.  Check it
out.  The talks are recorded so
you can catch up on them later.
The other point of our Google
I/O is it's about meeting people
and talking to the engineers
that work on the products.  If
you look at the top of the map,
there's a co-lab area.  Not
everybody has been to the
co-labs before, but you can sit
down and try the products out
yourself.  We have devices
plugged in and it's a lot of
fun.  We have engineers that
work on the products standing
around to answer questions and
help you out.  We have office
hours in the bottom right where
you can show up.  We have three
sessions for Android Things
where you can meet the engineers
and ask questions and also
we're around.  So if you see any
walking around, come and talk
to us and tell us what the idea
is, if you have any problems or
whatever.  We look forward to
hearing from you.  Finally,
what's next?  If you want to
learn more, join our Google+
communities, and we have three
for IoT, actions, and Assistant
and do a lot of postings to keep
people up-to-date.  I'm a
developer, so follow me on
Google+ and Twitter to keep up
to date with what I'm working
on.  What can you do with all of
this?  There are all kinds of
possibilities for IoT and
Internet of Things.  Think about
cool ideas you can build, but
also I want everyone to think
about what things you can
of people with accessibility
issues and people who could
benefit from more computing in
their lives to perform tasks
they can't currently perform.
This technology is changing the
world and I look forward to
building it with
LT.
Well
here to talk today about
accessibility.  So my name is
Patrick Clary.  I'm a product
manager on accessibility here at
Google, and I'll be kicking
things off.  a great group of
presenters from different areas
across Google with me here
today.  There's a few things
that I want you to take away
with you as you leave today.
first one is why designing for
accessibility is so important
and benefits our users, and this
isn't just users with a
disability or an accessibility
need.  I want to get across that
this actually helps all users.
The second thing you learn
about is
accessible on Android and hear
about what's comng on Android O!
And see new demos of these
things.  Tips for user research
for users with an accessibility
need.  You see an inside look
with a couple of examples on
things we have done at Google
and performed research on a
couple of different products.
very exciting.  First, why
accessibility?  So accessibility
is something that, you know, is
near and dear to my heart, but
I want to give you a few reasons
why it's important.  I'm
speaking to the developers.  Why
it's important for developers
to consider as well.  So here's
a metric I find very compelling,
right?  1 in 5 people will have
a disability in their lifetime.
a staggering number, so
addressing accessibility has a
direct benefit on these users.
a huge benefit.  It's a
life-changing benefit, so for
these users it means the
difference with connecting to
friends, families, really taking
advantage of the technology
that mainstream users really use
and enjoy.  The second, as I
mentioned, is that designing for
accessibility really benefits
all users.  Let me give you a
couple of examples.  First,
think about designing a product
that's meant for a blind or a
low-vision user.  When you do
this, you're actually helping
users that might have their eyes
occupied.  Perhaps they're
driving and looking at another
screen and not looking directly
at their Android device.   is
designing for a user with a
motor impairment, like a tremor.
It affects the use of a touch
screen and makes it difficult to
use a touch screen.  Designing
effectively for these users
actually benefits mainstream
users who otherwise can't use
the touch screen.  Maybe they're
holding groceries or cooking
but they can't use the touch
screen effectively.  When you
think about this way, designing
for accessible is about designs
for the widest possibility range
of abilities within the widest
range of situations.  It's not
about designing for
disabilities, it's about
designing for all
users.  So where does Android
fit in?  In Android we have a
series of settings and APIst.
It allow them to customize how
it looks and feels, right?  APIs
allow developers to build out
apps that meet the needs of
users with accessibility needs
and accessibility services.  So
an accessibility service is a
long-running privileged program
that runs on your device that
changes the way users consume
the content of your device or
changes the way they interact
with their device.  We have a
few here.  These are four that
Google has developed.  TalkBack,
BrailleBack, Switch Access and
Voice Access.
So TalkBack and BrailleBack are
services designed for users who
are blind or have low vision.
TalkBack is our screen reader.
This allows users to basically
interpret the content of their
device through an audio stream.
So users will listen to what's
on the device using TalkBack.
BrailleBack is similar, but
instead of an audio stream, want
content going to refreshable
Braille display.  a handheld
Braille device where a user can
scan their fingers across it and
interpret the content on the
screen.  We also have Switch
Access and Voice Access.  These
are two services targeted to
users with motor impairments, so
for example, as I mentioned,
users that have a tremor.  These
are users that typically can't
use a touch screen, so it's
Switch Access and Voice Access,
we provide full Android control
without having to touch the
screen.  So with Switch Access,
users typically use an adaptive
switch device.  You see an
example later, but this is a
physical hardware switch that a
user might have mounted in front
of them and mounted to a
wheelchair, and they'll tap on
the switch to linearly scroll
through things on their device.
actually allows users to
control the device purely by
voice.  You issue voice commands
that correspond to touch
controls like scroll up, scroll
down, tap, Gmail, go home, et
cetera.  So that's what we have
on Android.  For a deeper look
into the upcoming version of
Android, I'll hand it over to
Maya and Victor.
you, Patrick.  Maimcy victor
SaaS ran, and I'm a technical
program manager on the Android
accessibility processes team.
Android O! Our major focus was
to increase productivity for
users of accessibility services.
particular, we looked at users
blind and vision impaired and
used the TalkBack screen reader.
We introduce accessibility API
s to help developers to develop
services for people with
physical disabilities.  You have
a service called Switch Access.
but not least, we're
introducing the new
accessibility service, which
will help people with print and
learning disabilities to read
information on the screen.  Let
me start with new features for
TalkBack.  The first feature I
would like to talk about is
called accessibility volume.
the fancy words is an ability
for someone who is blind or
vision-impaired or specifically
using a TalkBack screen reader
to adjust the volume of speech
independently from the volume of
media.  For example, when
watching a YouTube video or
listening to music.   this by
introducing a new audio stream
in O called accessibility
stream.  As a developer of an
accessibility service, what that
means to you is that you will
have to request this feature
when writing your accessibility
service.   it is not available
to you.  So let me show you how
this feature works.
SPEAKER:   Go home.
Overview.  Settin
Open YouTube.   Showing items 1
to 2.  the developer
show.  Up developer show TL069,
11K views. This is
a typical situation.  I'm
trying to listen to TalkBack and
it's talking back to me.  I
can't hear anything.  What I can
do right now is completely shut
off the volume of the video,
and I can still hear TalkBack.
So this is essentially how it
works.  The TalkBack user is now
able to adjust the speech of
the -- the volume of the speech
independently from the media
volume.
More details and links.  You
also notice there's a new
accessibility volume slider at
the top of the screen.  That,
again, allows you if you're a
visual user, you can adjust this
slider as well from the volume
tray. Rewind.  Pause video.
Play video.  Home screen 1 of 2.
The next feature I would like
to talk about is -- has to do
with new gestures for TalkBack.
Many of the new Android devices
use a fingerprint sensor at the
back of their device, so we
decided why not utilize the
fingerprint sensor for
additional gestures to allow
TalkBack users to activate some
of the favorites of their
features.  So we're introducing
the ability for an accessibility
service such as TalkBack to
utilize the fingerprint sensors.
The gestures available to the
user are swiping left, right, up
or down.  These gestures are
unsignable, so you can decide
which TalkBack feature each
gesture will launch.  You have
to request a special flag to
take advantage of fingerprint
gestures.  Fingerprint gestures
work, again, only on O devices.
to point that out.  Let me show
you how this works.
3:10 p.m.  Home speed.  Chrome.
I'm going to attempt something
very brave.   a selfie.
Camera.  Camera.  I use
fingerprint gestures to do that.
Photo gallery, shutter, switch
to front camera. to back camera.
Right.   of screen.  Very
close.  faces.  Shutter.  Photo
taken.  Photo gallery.  One
face.  Centered.
)    SPEAKER:   Home screen 1
of 2.  These are the fingerprint
gestures in Android O! For
accessibility.  I would like to
talk about multilingual support.
One of the things we realized
since Android has been used so
much outside of the U.S., we
badly need to support
international users.  In O we're
introducing the Google
Text-to-Speech engine to
recognize languages appearing on
the screen and switch
Text-to-Speech to speak in that
particular language.  If you're
a developer and you would like
to trigger language automatic
switching, you can use
LocaleSpan to trigger the
change.  Before you get excited,
let me show you actually how
the language switch and feature
Device unlocked.   Overview.
Overview.  home.  Home.  Home
screen inbox.  Pick messages.
Inbox.  Remember subject
beautiful day, remember two.
11.  More menu.  Hi there.   my
wife, lovely wife likes to pull
little jokes at me.  Well, in
this particular case this is not
a joke.  She sent me a message
a few days ago to try and invite
me for dinner.  She does a
little thing in style.  This is
no exception.  She sent me a
message in four languages
because we're so cool, right?
deals with this particular
situation.  More menu.  Hi
there.
Speaking in non-English )
SPEAKER:   Let's have dinner
tonight.  Thank you.  So that's
likely both of us can speak
both the languages, and I was
able to understand what she
said.  It was French, Polish,
Ukrainian and Chinese for your
information.  The last thing I
want to talk about is the new
accessibility shortcut.  quite a
bit of time users ask us for an
ability to turn off the
favorite accessibility service
regardless of which screen
they're on.  They wanted a
shortcut key to press and the
service will toggle on and off.
example, if a blind person
walked into the store that sold
Android phones, they wanted to
be able to launch TalkBack and
start exploring the phone to
decide where they want to
purchase or not.  We introduced
in accessibility shortcut, and
it's configured to launch
TalkBack, but it can launch any
available accessibility services
on the device.  I want to point
out that this works on any
screen, even after you exit the
Setup Wizard.  Once the shortcut
is configured, it will be
available to the user at all
times.  As a developer of an
accessibility service, you have
to request this feature at this
time when you service it.   it's
not available to use.  It's
unavailable to accessibility
services.  As you can guess, the
demo is pretty simple.  I'll
show you how this works.  Home.
All I have to do right now is
press two volume keys at the
same time.
And the accessibility service
is off.  I press them again,
that's it.  That's how
accessibility shortcut works.
VICTOR TSARAN:  So as you
can imagine, I just scratched
the surface.  There's much more
coming up.  I would like Maya to
talk about this other exciting
services and APIs.  Thank you.
victor.
Thank you for the lovely demos.
My name is mara Ben Ari.  I'm
a product manager on Android
accessibility.  The next set of
features we're going to talk
about are new APIs to support
new framework support
functionality.  We're adding
continuous gesture API.  In
every nougat we added an API to
allow performing gestures on
behalf of the user.  In Android
O! We are extending this API to
make it easier to perform
continuous gestures.  What does
it mean?  It means that, for
example, it will be easier for
users using a wheelchair mouse
or hat tracker to perform
gestures such as drop, text
selection, answering phone calls
and zooming in and out of
next feature I'm very excited
about is called the
accessibility button in the
navigation bar.  What we added
here is a new button,
accessibility button to the
right of the navigation bar to
quickly invoke context-dependent
accessibility features.  Let's
give an example.  Right now we
have magnification.  So a user
using magnification can triple
tap to magnify the screen.
some users find it challenging
to perform the triple-tap
gestures.  In Android O we're
adding an alternative to invoke
magnification.  Let me show you
how this works.
So I have that accessibility
button on the bottom right of
the screen.  I can simply tap
the button, and if I tap
anywhere on this screen, I will
magnify the content.  Now, I can
move this around using two
fingers, and if I want to
demagnify it, I will just press
the accessibility button again.
Back to the slides.  Now, this
is optionally supported by
developers for devices with
software navigation bar.  The
button will be shown there only
if there is an accessibility
service or feature that supports
it and it is turned on.  The
next set of features are for
people with disabilities.  There
are people who have difficulty
reading text.  Those include
people with dyslexia,
far-sighted, low vision,
illiterate or even people that
want to learn a new
language.  We recently launched
a service called Select to
Speak.  Select to Speak is part
of TalkBack 5.2.  What the
service does is it vocalizes
content on the screen by a
llowing the user to select
elements to read.  Now, this
service is available for
Lollipop MRI and
up.  Now, this is an example of
how Select to Speak works.  You
can see a floating action
button.  Then the user can
either tap an element or select
-- marquee select elements to
read, and the content will be
read out loud.   We're adding
additional functionality for
Select to Speak, including
reading the whole page, advance
controller to move backwards or
adjust the speed.  We add
lighting and we integrated this
service into the Setup Wizard.
me show you how it works.
I have here the accessibility
button, and if I press on the
accessibility button, I can show
that also I have a service
which uses this button called
Select to Speak.  I will select
that one, and if I will tap the
button again, then I will be
shown a controller bar.  At this
point I can drag and drop or
move the controller bar on the
screen.
Now I can either support the
functionality I already have,
for example, I can marquee
select or tap an element.  Maps.
And it will be read out loud.
I can also have continuous
reading.  69 degrees Fahrenheit,
Wednesday may 17th, maps, play
store, Chrome, drive,    MAYA
BEN ARI:  I'll stop that one.
Now, we also have the Select to
Speak that can read the whole
page, and it can read the whole
sentences.  I can go backwards
and forwards with the sentences
and also increase and decrease
the speed by pressing the plus
and minus button.  Let me show
you how it works.  NAF gate out.
Speak.  Settings on.  tap
specific items on your screen
and then you can tap a specific
item.  Drag your finger across
the screen to select multiple
items.  Tap the play button to
hear everything.
Select to Speak available in
Android O! And with TalkBack
5.2.  The next section is about
testing.  We'd like to make
Android more accessible for
everyone.  Developers are a
crucial part of this mission.
develop better experience for
people with disabilities, but a
lot of it has to do with how you
test your app for
accessibility.  If in the next
section I'm going to talk about
manual and automated testing for
accessibility.  start with
manual testing. first thing that
you want to do is you want to
get familiar
with it and understand how the
experience works with Android
accessibility services like
switch talk and access.  Cover
your eyes and try to go through
the experience in your app.
like to notice whether your app
is representing correcting --
correctly the content for
TalkBack.  For example, maybe
you have unlabeled bottles or
maybe you're missing a
description or maybe you have
controls that are hard to
interact with.  Pay special
attention for issues that may
impact users
efficiencies while performing
common flows.  If it works well
with TalkBack, it will also
likely work well with
BrailleBack and Select to Speak,
because what you are doing is
you're actually testing your
app's output.  Your testing
whether you're representing
correctly your content to the
accessibility service.  It's
this.  The next thing that you
want to test is you want to test
with Switch Access.  As Patrick
mentioned, Switch Access is a
service started for users with
motor impairment who has
difficulty interacting with
their device.  In that case, the
user connects something, which
is called an adaptive switch.
an example of an adaptive
switch.  An adaptive switch can
contain two buttons or less or
more.  In that case the user
could use one  you don't have an
adaptive switch, you can just
connect an external key board
and map the certain keyboard
buttons to certain activities in
Switch Access.  After you do
that, you want to go through
common flow, and you want to
note whether Switch Access
interacts correctly with your
app UI.  If it works well with
Switch Access, it will also
likely work well with Voice
Access, because what you do at
that point, you're testing your
app input.  SICH  Switch Access
and TalkBack, you test the app
output and input.  Testing
Switch Access and TalkBack is
the best way for you to
understand the experience that
you are providing for users with
different needs.  But this is
not all, because there are
multiple other features
available on the platform
including magnification,
enlarged text.  To facilitate
accessibility testing, we also
provide a tool which is called
Accessibility Scanner.
is the stand alone app you can
downlead free from the play
store.  It's targeted for app
developer and QA testers, and
it's a way for you to improve
the accessibility of your app.
How you can use it?  Download it
and turn it on. see a floating
button on the screen.  You are
interesting into the foreground,
and press the button, and then
Accessibility Scanner will
analyze the UI and will show
some suggestion of how to
improve your accessibility and
in this example, an example for
improving the text contrast.  We
shipped this app in March of
last year, and we're very happy
to announce that in the last
year accessibility users used
the Accessibility Scanner to
find over 1 million
opportunities for improving
their app accessibility.  check
it out and download
Accessibility Scanner from the
play store.
A bit about automated testing.
We also created accessibility
testing framework to allow you
to perform out of meta testing.
framework is an OpenSource
library that provides runtime
evaluation on real Android UI
constructs.  We integrated this
testing framework into two --
into two common test frameworks
called
Roboelectric and Espresso.  If
you already use those, you can
simply turn on accessibility
test functionality within those
frameworks, and then you might
see some of your tests start to
fail because they could have an
improved accessibility.
Lastly, we launch a new section
about accessibility on
developer.Android.com.  This can
help you guide to better
understand how to
implement accessibility in your
app.   we have a page about
testing your app accessibility.
In general, we recommend a
balance between manual testing
and automated testing for making
your app accessible.  With this
page, the page summarizes how
you can develop a holistic test
strategy to improve manual and
automated testing.  With all
this testing, there is no better
way than interacting with
actual users and conducting user
research. For that, Astrid and
Melissa are going to tell you
all about that.  Applause )
ASTRID WEBER:  Thank you,
Maya.  I'm Astrid Weber and I
work on user experience research
for accessibility engineeringal
Google.   Melissa Barnhart.
What is UX research and why do
we need it?  you have a dream of
opening a bar.  How many of us
haven't had it at some point in
our lives.  You have these cool
designer deals for the interior
of your bar, and you know
exactly what you want to serve
on the drinking menu.  You
really know that the music
you're going to play is what you
basically have at home and you
play yourself.  Basically while
you're building your bar, you're
imagining how perfect a bar
could be if it would just be the
perfect place for someone with
exactly the same tastes like
yourself.  Basically, your users
are just like yourself, right?
are, unfortunately, that your
bar might be empty.  Your
business idea might be failing,
like over 50% of all bars and
restaurants are failing within
the first year of their
existence.  I'm pretty sure that
all the owners of these bars
and restaurants really wanted to
create a good experience and
really made choices that they
would have taken themselves.
brings us up to the importance
of user experience research and
design.  For restaurants and
bars and also for technology
development.   the failure rate
amongst start-ups is at 90%,
which is much higher than
running a bar or restaurant.  At
the same time, research shows
that if you are testing your own
assumptions and your user needs
often and early, your chances
increase so much more that you
will end up with a rated app and
satisfied users.  That brings
us very close to the definition
of actual and objective UX
research, which really is all
about changing your own
perspective to that of your
users to understand their needs
including all the accessibility
needs.  User research focuses on
understanding user behaviors,
needs and motivations for
various research techniques,
it's the process of
understanding the impact of
design on an audience.  Now that
we have a common understanding
of the concept of UX research,
what does it actually entail?
is a set of research methods
that can help you during the
whole process of your product
development cycle.  UX research
methods such as field studies,
interviews, or competitive
analyses are very well-suited in
the beginning of your product
development work, because they
are especially useful in order
to understand how technology
usage works and how new
innovative fields work.  you
have decided what to build and
you have a first prototype,
research methods such as
usability studies, participatory
design exercises or remote
research actually really are
useful for you to understand
what works and what doesn't work
in the hands of your users.
Lastly, once your product is out
there in the market, you really
want to understand how it's
doing, right?  Research methods
such as cognitive walk-throughs,
- no.  methods such as analysis
and studies as well as remote
testing really help you at that
stage of your product
development to understand how
the app is doing in the market
and if people really like it.
that, I hand it over to Melissa,
who has a very concrete example
for you from our recent
accessibility Android
development on O.   All right.
you, Astrid.  Today I'd like to
show you exactly how
accessibility resource has
informed the design process for
Android.  Let's take the
examples of settings.  We want
all users to easily access and
understand settings relevant to
them, including users with
accessibility needs.  Here we
have a screenshot of the
accessibility settings page for
Android N.  When planning for
Android O, we had assumptions
about this page.  We felt it was
a big unorganized making it
hard for users to find what they
need.  We questioned whether
services and system had any real
meaning to users, so we turned
to research to check our
assumptions and make more
informed design decisions.  We
used two research methods,
usability studies and
intercepts.  As Astrid
mentioned, they're well-suited
for design develop stage.  So we
started with usability studies.
these studies we invited
people with visual impairments
to our offices and prompted them
to interact with the
accessibilities settings page
you just saw.  We immediately
observed some issues,
specifically the participants
could not always find the
settings we asked them to find,
and even when they did, they
weren't sure what those settings
would do.  Our approach to this
research was iterative.  So we
learned things in one study,
adjust the design and then
retest the adjusted design in
the next study.  We wanted to
hear from a wider, more diverse
audience.  We went to a
conference.  In January we
attended the assistive
technology industry association
conference in Orlando, Florida
with just a clipboard, pen,
paper and phone, we approached
conference attendees and asked
them for 10 minutes of feedback
on the latest designs.  These
intercepts allowed us to gather
a lot of feedback in a
relatively short time frame.  In
two days we talked to 15 people
with visual, cognitive and
motor impairments as well as AT
professionals and educators.  As
a result of this research, we
verified a lot of our
assumptions, and fine tuned our
designs.  And here's a sneak
peek at the accessibility
settings page for Android O!.
right you see that we're
introducing categorizations by
utility.  Instead of categories
like services and system, you'll
find categories like screen
readers and display.  Also, we
added powerful icons to make
Android services pop.  Lastly,
below each setting we included a
short description to explain
what the setting does.  Now,
accessibility research helped
guy this design approach and it
can help you, too.  So if you
want to build products for the
widest possible audience and
genuinely improve people's
lives, consider incorporating
accessibility research into your
current process.  I promise you
don't need fancy equipment or a
big budget to get started.
about how you can talk to users
with accessibility needs.  Make
you attend a conference like we
did. you reach out to a local
organization or university.  you
have a friend with dyslexia or
color blindness who would be
willing to try the app and give
you 15 minutes of feedback.  Try
to include one person with
accessibility needs in your next
research study and see what you
learn.  The difference between
zero and a little data is
astounding.  With that I hand it
back over to Astrid.  Thanks,
Melissa.  Those of you works on
consumer-facing apps hopefully
already mark your calendars now
to conduct some accessibility
research as soon as we're back
in the office.  Those of you who
work on developing facing
applications might wonder, what
about my target group?  The good
news is they can also benefit
from UX research, and we have an
example of our very own
Accessibility Scanner app about
how the UX research really
helped us to develop a better
application.  We tested abbing
Accessibility Scanner with
designers, test engineers,
developers, and product
managers.  We did the early
stage prototypes with some paper
marks, and in addition to that,
we also tested the name itself.
you heard correctly.  was not
born with that name.  We had a
long list of options, but rather
just following our own
preference, we asked our users
in interviews because we wanted
to understand which name would
be most memorable and what
people are associating with each
of the options.
Thanks to UX research we made
visual and interaction design
changes to the application.  One
of the visual design changes
entails that we do not use
colors anymore to distinguish
the kind of issues being
detected.  a diverse sample of
users helped us there, because
the colorblind participants of
our study clearly signaled to us
that they felt left out of the
experience if you use color
because they could not
necessarily distinguish the
elements based on that factor.
improved the overall flow of
the application by making it
easy to click on any element of
detection and then get a short
description of the issue.  This
way the application became
especially useful and useable to
those new to accessibility
testing.  On that note, I will
hand it back to Patrick with our
final thoughts and an outlook
on
All right. you, Astrid.  So I
hope everyone's inspired to go
home, no work, look at own
products and apps and think
about the accessibility and the
benefit it has on these users.
Along those lines,ive a few
challenges to the developers in
the audience.  first one is
familiarize yourself with
accessibility services and these
APIs that were mentioned so
when you go home, turn on
TalkBack, turn on Switch Access,
put yourself in the shoes of
these users and run through your
apps to see what you uncover.
The second is to download
Accessibility Scanner, right?
Download it.  It's very easy.
You can get it and test your
app.  Very easy to find
low-hanging fruit and quick and
easy ways to improve the
accessibility of your app.
think about performing user
research with users that have an
accessibility need, so find a
family member, a friend, someone
in your community, go to a
conference and sit with them as
the user app, and I bet you'll
be surprised what things you
learn.  We have a few other
really interesting things happen
at Google I/O for
accessibility. we have a couple
other sessions, designing for
the next billion yours and
pragmatic accessibility.  We
have a sandbox back here.  This
is your chance to learn more
about accessibility and see the
demos and speak to a Google or
one on one and get more
information.  also have the --
on Thursday at 6:30 we have the
Google Play awards and there's
an awesome award for the best
accessibility experience.  I
recommend you check it out.  I'd
like to thank you, and keep in
touch.  Use our Twitter handle
@Google
Welcome everyone.  I'm Venkat
Rapaka.   of the Android team,
this is one of my favorite times
of year.  You get to come to
I/O and interact with the
community and a number of our
partners attend so we meet all
of them.  This year is exciting
for me because this is the first
time we get to talk at I/O
about Android Things and how to
bring it to more people.  You
probably heard earlier today at
the keynote that kicked it off,
Android now has incredible
momentum across a number of
verticals up here.  There are 2
billion devices, 2 billion
monthly active devices that run
Android across these four
factors.  Joining this family is
now Android Things.  Android
Things is designed to extends
Android beyond these four
vertical, mobile, wear, TV and
auto to a lot more exciting new
product categories within the
space of IoT.  At Google, it's a
very interesting area for us
with all the innovation
happening now, and we also see
that there's an opportunity and
a real need to enable us to
build high quality devices
quickly and easily.  There's an
opportunity to Democrat ties IoT
development and make it more
accessible to peoples.  Android
Things was created last year as
an acknowledgment of this
potential ahead of us.  Android
Things was released in December
last year, and it's been great
to see the excitement so far and
the momentum we've built up.
In fact, in the keynote this
morning already in the five
months up until now there are
thousands of developers in more
than 60 countries who are
actively trying Android Things,
so thank you very much for
investing your time and all the
feedback you've given us.  So
IoT, of course, is very broad
and diverse.  Within this large
space, Android Things is
targeted one of the most
exciting things for us, one of
the most exciting areas.
devices that sit at the edge and
bring in device intelligence,
and these devices span many use
cases old and new. see examples
on the screen.  The security
systems, Reuters, they've been
around for as long as we
remember.  There are new
interesting device types with
cameras believe into them.
retail increasingly you see
point of sale machines, vending
machine that have this place and
can interact with the
customer's mobile device at the
point of sale and do some very
interesting things.  When you
think of smart buildings, which
we talk about a lot, you have
cameras in there, and these
cameras cannot only detect
occupancy but can be a headcount
and say how many people are in
a given space at any point of
time and interact intelligently
with other systems in the
building like the HVAC system
and do something smart with the
knowledge.  Truly mobile IoT
applications like asset
tracking, fleet management, this
is becoming much better every
day with the ability to pull
context from the cloud and do
something smart with it locally.
you look at all of these
categories, you see very
interesting, common things
emerge.  One is powerful devices
that sit at the edge with
complex operations, image
processing, audio processing and
they do it all locally.
There's a lot of home device
intelligence, and this is for a
number of different reasons or
combination of reasons.   the
low latency that wants to react
quickly and other times it's the
tolerance.  all have a need for
deep security.  Both at the
device level, but also how they
interact with the cloud.
today, I think to build a
device, any of these types of
devices is not easy, so let's
talk about a few challenges that
we see in this spacespace, the
I/O developer space.  talk about
the software part of it.  If
you're a software developer, the
complexity that confronts you
is massive.  The you IoT devices
are built on Linux or Android,
so it's very difficult to get a
consistent and reliable API that
you can depend on.  It's hard
to find robust tools that you
can use, and it's also very hard
to find a community of
developers that can reach out to
when you run into trouble.
Think of all the basic building
blocks when you build a product.
To build a product for a
consumer application, even
something as simple as the
reliable setup flow so that the
consumer can use the mobile
device to set up the product
you're selling them as well as
an app that you can use to build
your own app.  If you think of
an enterprise use case, having
zero touch and having a fleet of
devices that may not be coming
from you but a combination of
devices from everybody.  In some
cases providing them APIs so
they can integrate into the
console they use.  You have to
build it from scratch to get
started.   it's really hard to
get -- it's really hard to get
access to third-party -- I'm
sorry.  I'm going too fast.
really hard to get access to
third-party services like the
Google Assistant and getting
them working out of the box,
especially if you build multiple
products in the space.  That's
the software part of the
problem.  When you get to
hardware SHS
things are more complicated,
right?  You have to pick them to
build a cohesive system, get
your code running on it.  You do
that to get to the prototype
stage and do a PROF of concept.
As you do this, you need to be
careful to make sure you pick
components that can have high
volumes when you hit high
production.  If you don't do
that, you have a bunch of work
you did before to adapt in the
new confidence you replaced them
with.  This is not a problem
that's unique to small or medium
companies.  Some of our largest
partners tell us how difficult
it is for them even if the scale
they're at, especially the
space with diversity of product
categories and portfolio, they
also started with this the same
way that a small company would
struggle.   security.  I think
given the amount of news --
news we see today, I don't need
to belabor the point of how
important security is in this
space, but I think especially in
the IoT scenario, it's harder
to deliver that security because
of the scale and diversity of
the types of devices.  To build
a really secure device or keep
it secure is incredibly hard.
So with Android Things our goal
is to try and SOFL solve all of
these problems for the
developers.   by bringing the
power of Android to help with
software development.  The
second one is is to provide a
choice of hardware solutions
that let you scale from
prototype to production with the
confidence you can do that in a
quick and easy way.  Finally,
you want to help keep your
devices secure.   talk a little
bit about what I mean by the
power of Android.  It cuts
across all three themes.  I
mentioned the 2 billion monthly
active users that Dave mentioned
today.  What makes that
possible is a number of things.
The most important of those is
the people that are in this
room, the developer community.
The rich community that we have
of Android app developers that
make a lot of this possible.
Also, we have a number of
commercial entities and a supply
chain composed of silicone
providers, people that make
components, device
manufacturers, retailers, and
cellular operators, and it's a
collection of all of these, all
of you that makes Android what
it is.  It's a very, rich,
diverse, vibrant eco-system, and
that's what we want to bring to
the world of IoT.  Let's talk
first about the developer
experience and discuss how
Android Things can make this
very consistent and familiar to
a lot more people.  What you see
here is the typical Android
mobile device, the form.  Going
from bottom to top, the kernel
in the libraries focus on
hardware driver support.  The
middle stack, the application
framework provides the apps with
a number of partners and Google
builds to deliver a variety of
services and use cases.  This is
designed for devices of a
specific kind.  All of them have
a display.  They all expect
users to install apps, so
there's a very specific notion
that's built into these.  We
know that IoT devices don't
exactly fit this mold.  So we
set out to create a variant of
Android that's designed for IoT,
which is what Android Things
is. first things they do is they
used most of the user-facing
applications and a lot of visual
framework components.  Just as
an example, you don't need a
text messages app on most IoT
devices or on any of them.
While we did this to remove
unnecessary complexity that
developers face, one of the
happy side effects is we reduced
the footprint which makes it
scalable downward with IoT
devices.  Then we added a number
of new capabilities for IoT
devices.  Let me start with the
I/O.  It's part of the Android
Things library, and it provides
new APIs that allow applications
you would build that interface
using industrial standard
protocols like GPOI and IPS and
so on on the screen.  What this
enables is the APIs, your
application and code can
interpret with simple things
like buttons, relays, proximity
sensors and displays and
speakers and high-speed.  Over
time we have things like bar
code scanners, modified readers
and so on.  The second thing is
something -- the second thing is
user drivers, which enables an
interesting use case for us.  In
a lot of cases, your
applications can just use the
I/O, but in some cases you might
want to integrate your hardware
with the framework so you can
manage the call-backs and expose
the components thereof to other
applications that sit on your
product from a third-party, for
example.  Again, there's a few
quick examples.  Input devices
that generate key events or
motion events inject them into
the framework.  Think of the GPS
or other location sources that
are attacked to your product,
and this can be integrated with
the location framework.  Once
you do that, location updates
from these sources will then be
delivered through the location
manager and the providers.  So
over the last five months at
Google we added drivers on the
OpenSource community get hub
page, and we have noticed that a
lot of our developing partners
are contributing as well, which
is really awesome to see.  some
of our partners are also getting
into the act now just as an
example until recently added
support for Android Things with
their use of packages and
modules and MRA, which brings
with it about 200 very
interesting components and
profiles that now work on (?)
you use Android Things.
I mentioned we moved a lot of
visual framework components, and
we did it because a lot of IoT
devices don't have displays, but
quite a few have displays,
sometimes more than one.  This
display support is
optional, right?  It's the same
UI tool kit in all other Android
factors, so it relies on the
same framework.  If you build a
device with a display, the
entire display, the control for
the entire display is handed to
your application that you build.
we did is we got the system out
of the way.  So no more systems
status bar, navigation buttons,
we eliminated a lot of APIs
that don't make sense.  system
notifications and we removed all
of this, and we believe this
more closely mimicking the types
of devices in the IoT space.
They're fixed purpose and the
users interacting with the
Internet purpose as eposed to
adding new functionality on the
device.   connecting with it a
little bit.  Today in the
developer previews that we see
so far, we support WiFi and
Bluetooth.  We'll bring in NFC
later this year, but the one I'm
excited about is cellular.
cellular capabilities unlocks a
variety of very exciting new use
cases, but adding cellular
support is nontrivial, as anyone
has tried to connect us to.
What you find is that half the
challenge is actually enabling
the functionality and makes sure
it works.  You have to make
sure it works on carrier
networks, especially with a
geographic footprint in one
country.  The challenge goes up
dramatically.  core Android
teamworks with a number of
silicon partners in the context
of mobile phones to deliver the
capability.  As it turns out
WEESHGS working with some of the
same partners very closely as
well.  So we're going to LEFRM a
leverage a lot of work on
Android Things over the course
of the this DWREER.  support
Android Things on the processor
that has
modem capability.  I talked
about the changes we made and
what we added.  Let's talk about
what we did not change, which
is the core eco-system that
Android brings with it.  You can
continue to leverage the
Android SDK to develop your use
cases and AP case on top and all
the development tools that they
provide you.  You can continue
to use the existing third-party
Android libraries, and you can
continue to tap into the rich
community of Android app
developers for support and also
re-use things other built,
right?  That's one of the excite
things that Android can bring
to Android Things.  Play
services.  Google Play services
has a number of very interesting
APIs people rely on.  This is
currently only available in
Android Things and developer
preview.  What we're working on
is an optimized, much lighter
weight version of services at
IoT devices later this year.  We
didn't move a number of APIs we
didn't think were useful in
this case.  Things that enabled
user input or account
management, which don't make
sense in IoT.   the footprint by
a Lowell.  We used APIs like
five base, and we
add enhanced APIs that support
development on the device.  I
mentioned Firebase.  valuable
tool in this case.  The ability
to access
goingplot farm and we make it
seamless as well, that gee
integration.  The system would
be launched in a sample
yesterday that lets you build a
Google Assistant prototype
usings Android Things.  You'll
see more Google services and
apps that we will bring in
Android Things in a modular way
to pick the ones you want.  So
when we put all of this together
what you get is if you're an
Android app developer, this
opens up the world of IoT
devices to you and you can set
out on a path to be an IoT
developer yourself.  If someone
has an idea and you want to
build a device, you can tap into
this community of app
developers and you don't have to
build a full team any longer to
get started.  You can pick some
things you build and tap into
the large community and get
going.  Finally, we did talk
about devices getting
increasingly smaller.  We'll
talk about how we make it
happen.  So on device
intelligence is going to be
critically important in IoT over
time, and this is for a number
of reasons.  One is latency.
might want a quick response
time.  You might have bandwidth
constraints.  It's expensive
times.  The connectivity might
be unreliable and so on, right?
Android, the core Android
platform itself
and with Android Things, we're
making as a collective deep
investments to bring device
capabilities in a deeply
integrated fashion into the
distributions we're going to
provide you.  We added support
for Tensor Flow on Android
Things.  It's awesome to see the
creative things our community
is building so far.  The most
space you can see Tensor Flow in
action, is one that our team
built and another one someone in
the community built using the
companies that delivered
already.  There's also a core
Tensor Flow that you can get
your hands on it.  So I'm going
to switch gears a bit now and
move from so the  -- software to
hardware and how Android Things
will simplify the prototyping
process as well.  If you're
getting started on a new device,
you need to assemble the right
components and make sure they
work together and the proof of
concept works and it's at scale
at a price you're able to pay.
when you get to mass production,
and there's a lot of complexity
involved in this and time as
well.  To help with this, it
uses the sum architecture.  I
think a lot of here in the
audience are familiar with this
concept.  A SoM basically has a
core computing model.  It
computes connectivities, storage
and many other core competence
in a small package.  When you
build an IoT device, some of the
most complex device is
encapsulated in the SoM itself.
What you see here on the left
side, my left, are two modules,
one from Intel and one from
Expedia we already launched.  In
close collaboration with our
silicon partners, we will
provide a BSP, a Board Support
Package for your code to reside
on top of it.  portable to other
platforms as you build out a
portfolio of lower capable
devices in the same category or
you switch to a new category and
want something quite different.
Let's see how a SoM is in
action.  It's pretty hard to see
on the slide how big these SoMs
are.  The small image up there
is this.  This is what a SoM
looks like.  It's about an inch
and a half on the side, roughly
a square.  The larger image
there is the baseboard that we
use internally.  It's a (?) That
we use internally.  It has the
kitchen sink of all the
connections we need our internal
prototyping and development and
testing.  Of course, the
product you build won't require
all of these XEN components so
you would have a baseboard
simpler and what you need for
your product.  This tends to be
a lot less expensive to produce
at lower volumes, so the
prototyping is easier once you
use a SoM.  The SoM model, we
believe, offers key advantages.
is to get to the prototype
stage much faster taking off the
shelf components.  The
precertified hardware takes
development costs and taking
technology risk inHARNTS as you
build the prototypes.  Of
course, as you scale to larger
commercial volumes, you can be
confident you can procure this
in high volume.  If you hit high
volumes, you can collapse the
baseboard and a SoM into one
board.  You can get a custom
board built for you.  It has a
couple of advantages.  One is it
can reduce your cost, and
another thing you can then lay
it out in a way that matches the
XY dimensions of your product,
right?  So you can optimize it
to fit exactly clearly into the
product I.D. you want to build.
you use the same BSP, you don't
have to rewrite any code you
already built.  If you want to
learn more about SoMs and how to
build custom space for your
custom boards, I think there's
more detailed talk at 9:30 a.m.
So, of course, you need SoMs
that match the price and power
and performance and connectivity
needs that your product has.
So to do this, we're working
with a number of industry
leaders to make sure you have
plenty of hardware choices.
Today we support Intel and
RaspberryPi and Qualcomm and
we're working on the snapdragon
210 line and working with media
tech with Android Things
supports on it.  Finally, I'll
talk about security.  Thankfully
there is now an increasing
focus on security in IoT.  In
IoT space, the challenge is
dramatically higher for a number
of reasons.  One is just the
diversity of the device types,
the diversity of the operating
systems and the had wear that's
underneath in the use cases.
how the devices are used today,
right?  A lot of them operate
with no user intervention or
interaction.   display where you
can say something to the user,
and a lot of them are out of
sight out of mind.  I can't
remember the last time I looked
at my WiFi router sitting in a
closet in my stairs.  It's also
hard to keep the device secure
over a period of time.  Android
Things has been designed for
security from the ground up.
see here is two separate parts
of the code.  One is the OS
that's provided by Google in
close collaboration with our
Silicon partners.  This is
created by the app developers.
This is your apps and your user
drivers and so on. two is a very
clean Android API layer.  We
can update either two partitions
independent of the other
without compromising the
functionality of the product.
It allows us to push that up.
So I talked about security
updates just now.  So the
Android is a part of investing a
lot of energy into delivering
monthly security updates, which
we bring to the IoT space to
Android Things.  partitions are
signed by a trusted source for
security.  suspects verified
good so your devices are
protected against things you
download and it will block your
device from booting into an
unknown state with an image or
signal you don't trust or the
contents you cannot verify.
also updates.  You roll back, so
if you push something out by
accident, that compromises the
functionality.  always a good
image on the devices so without
having to do something in the
field, they went back to that
and put the device back up and
recover from there.  To push all
of these updates and to give
you the control on rollbacks and
also monitor your devices,
we're building currently a
developer console we give you
access to soon.  This same
console built on Google
infrastructure, you can use that
to push updates as well.  As
you come up with security
patches and extend the features
and functionality of your
partition, you can use them to
push updates.  It gives you the
ability to make your devices
better using the Google back
end.  To quickly summarize, with
Android Things we're going to
bring the power of Android to
simplify software development.
to provide you a choice of
hardware solutions that allow
you to scale from prototype to
production easily and quickly.
We EP had  -- we will help you
keep your devices safe and
secure.  Let me talk a bit about
where we are.  preview (?)
Yesterday. added I2S support
that lets you connect up audio
external devices like speakers,
for example.  We added a new
SoM, dynamic 7D that delivers
higher performance than the 6UL
we have support for.  I
mentioned that sample that we
delivered so you can prototype a
Google Assistant, a Google
Home-like product for yourself
using one of the SoM Z in our
Android Things.  In July we hit
developer preview 5, and rebase
2.0 at this time.  We have a
number of new features and we
will launch the developer
console into preview mode at
that time.  And later this year
we're going to have a number of
new features coming.  We'll have
updates, developer updates
every six to eight weeks.  We'll
have the GMS code for IoT.
We're going to have new features
like support and smart setup
with matching apps.  We have a
lot more SoMs coming from other
partners you saw just now.
towards the very end of the
year, we're going to release
Android Things to long-term
support, and it's going to be
based on O at the time, so you
have (?)
.  We'll use them as well.
Tomorrow we have a number of
interesting sessions coming up
that go a lot more into depth on
some of the topics I briefly
touched upon.  These are all the
sessions coming up.  If you
want to learn more, please go
attend them.  We also have a
demo area in the IoT sandbox
dome where you can Tensor Flow
in action and we have several
labs where you can get your
hands dirty and how it works
well with the Google Cloud.  You
can see what they're up to and
where we're going.  The
additional resources beyond I/O,
I'll go in order.  top link is
a link to our Google+ community
of developers where our
community can come to us to get
updates from us, to get support
from each other as well as our
team.  We're pretty active in
the community now and answer
questions when needed.   link is
a Ling to Google broader IoT
page.  The last one is our
developer documentation page,
and it has a number of resources
including core samples that you
can try out.  So this concludes
our talk.  Thank you, everyone,
for coming.Applause )
VENKAT RAPAKA:  Do we have
any Q & A?
We can do Q & A if anyone has
questions.
Let me introduce the folks on
the team. Wayne and this is SAM,
Lee Campbell, who was one of
the core TLs on the team and (?)
of the developer relations
team.  These four gentlemen have
been part of the team well
before I joined from the early
part of Android Things.  They're
giving me time to answer
questions now.  If anyone has a
question, come up to the
microphone here.  I have a
question, please.  What to do
with existing devices?  There
are like a billion devices in
the Internet of Things around
the world that are secured and
unsecured and compatible and
uncompatible.  What do you do
with them?  I think at this
stage, Android Things is more
forward-looking.  To the extent
the SoMs are compatible, you can
look at them.  Look at
OpenSource to also deliver more
security to the devices that
already shipped out there.
Android Things itself, the way
we deliver this as a binary,
it's more designed for the SoMs
and very forward-looking.  Okay.
you.  Sure.  Will things be
OpenSource fully or kind of
OpenSource?   OpenSource for
OSP, so it's part of that by the
end of the year when we're
ready.  Cool. you.  All right.
any suggested strategies on
creating actual production
hardware?  Obviously, you can't
have an SD card that can be
removed.  So yeah.  I'm not sure
I quite got it.  You're asking
about production hardware?  The
thing with the SoMs is the SoM
itself is something you buy.
board that it plugs into you
custom-build yourself.  You
don't have to build an SD card
into it.  You think about the
RaspberryPi that includes one.
other boards don't include them.
The storage is in the SoM
itself.  You can customize that
board with whatever you want,
and there doesn't have to be an
SD card unless you put one on.
Do you suggest using the SoMs in
like a developer setting, or
will you guys provide support
for creating integrated
components that hobbyists and
small companies can use?  We do
already.  provide a developer
board in the co-lab area.
There's a SoM and a board
everything plugs into.  So there
are developer kits you can
experiment with a board and
things like that.  You can try
RaspberryPi as well.  what works
for you.  The SoM-based
developers have a developer kit
as well.  I'll add, I think as
we go to the more interesting
categories, you will see us do a
lot more to provide nor turn
key solutions for that category
with the competence we can
support.   do you see Android
Things fitting into use cases
where you might otherwise use
the realtime SO that's time
critical?  Lee, do you want to
take that?  At the moment
Android or any Linux system
isn't ideal for realtime
operations.  Normally people do
a realtime coprocessor.  You see
people doing it and putting a U
in between them.  We're looking
into how we can provide an
obstruction for that so we can
provide realtime code inside an
APK on chip or off chip.  So
watch the space.  Thank you. You
menninged about Bluetooth and
cellular, and is there any plan
to add zigby support?  Not at
this stage.  We're looking at
it.  No plan on the roadmap yet.
The focus is on controllers.
Is there any plan for a (?)
Lightweight one with sensors
themselves?  No, Android Things
is designed for something more
capable.  A lot of those Edge
devices require our solutions,
so we're looking at it.  No
plans as of now.  You can find
controllers on the breakout
boards.  So you can essentially
communicate because ZB uses one
of the articles that we support.
Thank you. They mentioned over
there the hardware.  What other
boards will be coming in?  Is it
possible to use our own
hardware that we built and use
the SDK with Android Things?
Assuming that we build our own
boards, so is it possible to use
that customized
hardware?  If you build your
own board, it won't work.  You
need to pick a supported one
precertified by us.  That's
good.  Thank you.  Hello.
curious whether there's a time
line for using Android Things
for live video trans coding and
video processing.  like the
media coded API with the surface
based encoder and whether
there's a time line for that
with camera module support or
we'll be bound to camera modules
you select and most drivers are
not user space drivers?  The
media staff depends on the
hardware.  As we bring on the
more powerful chips from
Qualcomm and media tech, they
support the harder based
co-decks on your phone.  The low
end hardware doesn't have it as
you expect.  With regard to
cameras, at the moment we do it
with an accredited list of
sensors that work with that chip
to see.  This is pretty typical
anyway if you buy a Qualcomm
chip, they give you a list of
sensors they accredited for that
device.  We piggyback on the
same list.  If you want to take
a sensor that isn't supported
with Android Things, you have to
work and get it supported.
same situation with Android
Things.  You need to make that
match and do the ISP work and
all those things.   get on the
list, we'll naturally support
it.  Steps back for a second,
cameras are a very important
category, stand-alone cameras or
other devices.  You see us
invest very deeply in the area.
from a hardware point of view,
hardware and software and also
the (?)
Capabilities.   two questions.
If you have some kind of plan to
have them later, if I develop
one that won't connect and do it
later?
we're working on it internally
at the moment.  debate is how
useful it will be to developers
because most of the fun of using
Android Things is you can
interact with real hardware.  On
emulator you can't.  You can
run an Android app in software
without any embedded
peripherals, and that's not much
different than how it stands
today.  Running on a normal
phone, to be honest with you.
We'll be doing emulate targets
for things like continuous
integration and testing, but
we're debating how many value it
is inside Android Studio
itself.  you. second question is
about somebody already asked it
but I still want to ask.  FIPT
to create a custom board, is
there any way in your future
plan to generate this code to
some kind of byte code so I can
load it on my custom board?
Like a byte code of my program
to load to my custom board?
(?).  If you take our full
operating system, if you take
parts of Android that's AOSP.
the code is that, but in terms
of long-SMENT and security
updates, that's only for the
certified boards.  About the
emulator, if you have any
concrete use case, we would love
to hear.  We can talk offline.
We want to hear how useful that
will be.
So our appear indication is
cellular, and the question is,
what's the shortest path to
cellular connectivity with this
on the Verizon network,
including the challenges of
carrier certification?  RAPAKA:
You're two steps ahead of us.
We want to deliver that.  Step 1
is a SoM with leader
capabilities.  what they're
working on right here.  We're
seeing how we can make it easy
to not just get the board and
use the right network with
precertification, and also to
get access to data.  do you buy
data in the right granularity
you want in the fleet.  That's
what we're working on.  Time
frame on some of these carrier
boards? are you thinking?
hard to say right now.  I'm
sorry.   long time away?
Hopefully not, but yes.  I have
a question about Android Things
Tensor Flow.  Is there any place
to share things they're
building outside of the play
store, which are both hardware
drivers and models with Tensor
Flow?  Absolutely.  you know
better than I do all the
resources.   to share drivers,
you have two options.  We have
the complete drivers on
GitHub.  You can send PR
requests for us.  wondering if
there are people doing something
with Tensor Flow, and that
might reshare their depositores
for other things they're doing?
For now if you have it on
GitHub you can publish it on on
the Google+ community.  That's
where we share it and it's
useful to developers.  With that
we're out of time.  Maybe we
can answer questions separately
on the side if that's okay so we
can clear out the space.  Thank
you.  Applause )